[Musique]
31% des femmes estiment encore
aujourd'hui ne pas pouvoir parler de
sexualité comparé aux hommes et pourquoi
pourquoi parce que la liberté a toujours
accordé plus de liberté aux hommes qu'au
femme
parce que la société a toujours permis
aux hommes de pouvoir s'exprimer de plus
le plus naturellement possible sur leurs
envies leurs fantasmes
leurs besoins
les femmes avec le temps
elles se sont cantonnées dans ce rôle
elles ont appris à se taire
elles ont été là juste pour écouter
et non pour dire
et puis ne dit-on pas que lorsque une
femme parle de sexualité c'est pas beau
c'est pas joli c'est vulgaire
à la Réunion comme partout ailleurs
le tabou est encore présent
territoire de tradition
où la religion ce côtoie
difficile de parler sexualité
difficile de pouvoir en parler librement
surtout lorsqu'on est une femme
bonjour je m'appelle
Erica j'ai 43 ans
j'enseigne le français aux étrangers et
je suis maman d'une fille de 11 ans
aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer quel
a été mon parcours quel a été mon
parcours pour y arriver
quel a été mon parcours pour réussir à
émanciper ma parole ma propre parole
autour de ma sexualité
alors il faut savoir que je viens d'une
famille traditionnelle
pratiquante
indienne descendante
et à la maison la sexualité ce n'était
pas le sujet qui revenait le plus
j'ai été au collège
j'ai été une élève
sérieuse discrète donc aujourd'hui être
là devant vous c'est vraiment un grand
pas un grand pas que j'ai pris et que je
vous ai prendre
au collège je me rappelle
que j'ai toujours été
celle qu'on attendait de moi
il fallait bien apprendre à l'école
il fallait réussir et les garçons
c'était des femmes à priorité
au lycée même chez ma
discrète
moi j'étais plutôt abonné le week-end à
la médiathèque de Saint-Pierre alors que
mes copines
et ben je voyais bien que les histoires
de garçons de sortie en discothèque
c'était leur quotidien
et puis je vous avoue que au lycée
on nous n'a jamais parlé de sexualité en
tout cas mon époque dans les programmes
l'éducation sexuelle n'était pas
obligatoire
alors c'est vrai vous vous posez
sûrement la question mais comment
comment en fait j'ai été en contact avec
ce sujet
et bien
grande surprise ce fut mon père mon père
je me rappelle encore comme si c'était
hier
il me dit de venir au salon je me
rappelle que c'était l'année de ma
première je passais mon bac de français
et il me dit viens j'ai quelque chose à
te dire
j'arrive il avait un air sérieux
j'avais peur parce que je me dis bon je
m'entendais pas du tout à ce qu'il
allait dire et là il me dit attention la
sexualité
attention aux grossesses attention au
MST et ne jamais oublier les
préservatifs
c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé ce discours
étrange parce que je n'étais ni
amoureuse je n'avais ni petit copain et
autour de moi j'avais pas de copine qui
avait connu un épisode de grossesse
précoce
et je me disais voilà je comprenais pas
pourquoi ils me disait et je pense que
c'était plus par un devoir en fait en
tant que parents
car réel intérêt pour le sujet
et ensuite je me dis que rien n'arrive
par hasard et que l'univers a parfois il
met des signes
j'ai malgré moi
rencontré un livre qui était à la maison
alors il faut savoir que je suis une
morue de lecture j'adore lire je crois
que la lecture pour moi c'est une vraie
thérapie encore aujourd'hui
et ce livre je voyais toujours en fait à
la maison
mais
je m'étais jamais intéressé à lui alors
pourquoi aujourd'hui je ne savais pas
c'est un livre jaune avec une belle
couverture dorée et un livre avec un
titre minimaliste
je prie ce livre
et je me rappelle avoir parcours quelque
part et être resté 10 minutes à côté de
la bibliothèque de la maison à lire la
préface et là ce fut un choc un choc
parce que je découvrais un monde
agréable un monde d'émotion de ressenti
de plaisir
un monde qui était en total
contradiction avec ce que m'avait dit
mon père
discours très alarmant
et je ne comprenais pas je ne comprenais
pas pourquoi d'un côté on parlait de
danger et d'un autre on parlait de
plaisir
je pense que c'est le choc de ces deux
informations qui finit en moi
cette envie d'en découvrir plus
et je crois que la graine était plantée
j'avais envie de découvrir par moi-même
j'avais envie
de répondre à toutes les questions que
je me posais intérieurement
et j'avais peut-être indirectement envie
de découvrir la vérité
l'année suivante je rentrais à
l'université
et là
bon nombre de mes copines
rêvaient de Prince Charmant d'amour
romantique
d'être en couple
et moi j'étais à contre-courant
j'avais envie d'explorer
je crois que pertinemment le fait aussi
d'avoir été loin de sa famille
me donner cette impression de pouvoir
être la personne que j'avais envie
d'être
alors j'écoutais cette petite voix en
fait au fond de moi
et je continue à explorer
je pense quand on inspire à être la
personne qui on est
et ben l'univers met des personnes qui
vous aident
à être cette même personne je suis
beaucoup de rencontres des rencontres
riches
des rencontres intéressantes
qui me permet de découvrir la femme que
j'étais qui me permet de découvrir mon
corps
et je si je pouvais vérifier que les
hommes que mes partenaires masculins
étaient vraiment plus à l'aise que moi
de parler de leurs besoins de leur
fantasmes de leurs envies moi j'étais
toujours encore gênée et je ne
comprenais pas je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi il y avait cette telle
différence entre un homme et une femme
je vous avoue que
je me suis posé la question
je trouvais cela injuste
et je me disais que parce que je suis
une femme est-ce que parce que je suis
une femme je ne peux pas parler
librement de ma sexualité de mon corps
j'étais un peu en colère
mais je décidais toujours de suivre
cette petite voix
en 2020
je suis notre rencontre qui change à ma
vie
j'écrivais beaucoup aussi à cette époque
comme ma parole n'était pas aussi simple
à dire ça à travers les mots un petit
carnet que je tenais j'écrivais des
nouvelles des poèmes
érotiques et j'ai découvert
que
une fois lancée
et bien
on pouvait recevoir de belles surprises
je rencontrais une autrice
franco-indienne qui était venu en fait à
la Réunion pour parler d'un livre mais
pas n'importe lequel
c'était un livre qui parlait de femmes
de la sexualité de femmes
je trouvais qu'on avait beaucoup de
points communs on partageait notre amour
pour la littérature
on parlait notre intérêt pour la
sexualité et nous partageons également
notre initialité
implicitement je crois que je me
retrouvais en elle comme une sorte de
modèle
le livre malheureusement ne reçu pas
tout l'accueil qui lui était mérité
selon moi
il fait interdit
il fait interdit à être présenté dans
une médiathèque de Lille
je trouvais encore cela injuste un juste
pourquoi en 2020 un livre pouvait être
interdit
interdit parce qu'il osé par les
sexualité
je trouvais qu'on était
encore à une époque très arriéré
je me disais que les choses vont jamais
avancer
et vous savez quoi cela ne m'a pas
découragé
cela m'a encore plus motivé
elle m'encouragea d'ailleurs
à écrire à continuer d'écrire à
continuer d'écrire sur cette nouvelle
cette nouvelle est routine car de vous à
moi les doutes m'ont souvent parcourus
et c'est ce que je fis
j'avais en moi
cette petite voix qui me disait que
j'étais investie investi de porter la
voix des femmes ici à la Réunion et de
les porter très haut
de s'exploration à s'exploration
d'écriture en écriture ma parole se
libère et
je pouvais le remarquer car quand
j'étais invité chez des amis j'en
parlais librement je parlais de ma
liberté sexuelle d'être une femme
libérée
et
peu de temps après sur les conseils d'un
ami je m'inscris sur un site libertin
alors vous savez ça pas été facile parce
que phénomène d'insularité comme on sait
que à la Réunion tout se sait ça a été
difficile et quelles contradiction
aujourd'hui me retrouver devant vous et
de vous dire et de partager ça avec vous
je le fis et
ce site fut un incroyable observatoire
sociologique pour moi
je suis des rencontres encore
extraordinaires
les femmes aux paroles des complexées
pouvaient s'exprimer sur leurs besoins
sur leurs envies et je voyais aussi que
le rapport de force homme et femme était
inversé
je voyais que la parole
était puissante
que lorsque une femme se réapproprie sa
sexualité
et c'est reconnecte à sa liberté
la graine était plantée sans le savoir
et la boucle presque bouclée enfin
presque
avec tout ce que j'avais entendu tout ce
que j'avais appris et tout ce que
j'avais vu tout ce que j'avais
déconstruit autour de ma parole autour
de ma sexualité
j'avais envie d'en faire quelque chose
il était évident qu'il fallait que je
partage quelque chose
et c'est ce que je suis l'année dernière
je crée une page Instagram
pour parler de mes expériences
et de celle de toutes les femmes qui
voudraient bien le faire
le podcast reçu la page Instagram pardon
reçu un bel accueil
j'ai été agréablement surprise
j'étais agréablement surprise parce que
je me disais qu'à la Réunion finalement
la réunion n'est pas un mythique il
n'était pas hermétique au changement
et que lorsqu'on prend la peine de
prendre la parole et de la donner on a
le pouvoir on a le pouvoir de changer
les choses
alors
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je sais qu'il est important
qu'il est important de s'affranchir du
regard d'autrui
qui n'est pas évident de prendre la
parole sur des sujets aussi intimes que
ça
mais que si nous avons l'intime
conviction
et que nous y croyons très fort
alors il faut oser
oser
oser être soi
et dessiner le chemin
le chemin que nous voulons parcourir et
ne pas les autres le faire ne laissez
pas les autres décider à votre place
la société
a toujours appris aux femmes à se taire
la société n'a jamais appris les femmes
à prendre la parole en public
la société nous a beaucoup invisibilisé
aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment un grand pas que je vais
et je suis contente d'être devant vous
c'est que j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est que
il est important pour une femme de se
découvrir
peu importe les chemins par lesquels
vous allez passer peu importe les
expériences que vous allez vivre il est
important de se découvrir et de savoir
qu'il en est
que plus nous parlerons de sexualité
plus nous les verrons la parole à propos
de ce sujet
que parler c'est exister
que parfois il faut se heurter à des
normes établies pour changer les choses
et que lorsqu'on est une femme
il faut savoir parfois ne pas rester à
sa place
il faut savoir prendre la parole
n'attendez pas on vous la donne
et
causer prendre la parole savoir le
pouvoir de changer l'algorithme d'une
réalité bien établie
le travail ne fait que commencer
et avec vous qui pas arriver
merci
[Applaudissements]